If I could send a video to my 16-year-old self
(huh) I would send her so much wisdom
1: put your needs ahead of others
16 year old Anna, I know it's tough
because you are so romantic
but for hell, give yourself some love
Or else
Ask, you, another person
to give you all that approval and love
you need to work
and it's not only unreasonable for him,
but it is a "co-dependent" relationship with you
for the next decade
"co-dependent" relationship after "co-dependent" relationship.
So let's not learn it, the hard way.
Time travel, come on!
2: I always have hair problems
because, I felt like, my hair is flat and dull,
and if I stick close to my face, I look like a nun.
What the hell!
What you do is: you take 3 to 4 sections
or maybe 2 to 3
you double them, spray them
you take the pages, you toupere,
you spray, you do it
and eventually you curl it
And it looks like a million
3: Don't take other girls down.
Stop hating other girls.
Stop feeling threatened, insecure and jealous
because it just gets in the way
to know a really cool person
You know, nobody can be you
No one is you
So it really doesn't make sense to feel some kind of competition.
I'd rather go up to a girl and say:
"Oh my gosh! I fucking love you! All this"
"I don't know you, but I love you!"
Instead of being like (slander)
Because, really?
THE? What the hell is that"?
"THE"? is not getting to know another person
"IT? S:" I miss all kinds of amazing girlfriend dates
where we could have dinners and cocktails
and "farmer" and having fun
and one with whom I could have a lifelong friendship
someone who really cares about me "
Then 16 year old Anna
get together!
And love other girls because they are fucking cool
4: Go for what you want
Do not be afraid
No one can go after your career for you.
No one can maintain your relationship,
or your friends, or ask that guy out for you.
Who cares about you? Be brave!
You don't want to lie on your deathbed and be #repletters
You will lie on your deathbed:
"YES! I do everything I want
and if I couldn't, I tried "
And lastly: Make belts out of love
It's something I focus on in therapy,
and if you are not in therapy, you should be in therapy,
because we have all our problems in life,
But, I've spent a lot of my life making decisions based on what I was afraid of.
and it was not good for me
and it was not good for the people in my life,
so now this is something I would like to try to change.
I will make decisions that are best for those I care about
including myself
Be happy. Take off and travel.
See the world. Say yes to people
Meet friends. Remember to exercise.
Drink water. Take your vitamins
Respect your body. Respect your mind
Adopting all your animals you find it sensible to take care of.
Don't be so hard on yourself
Keep being cool, Gotham
Subtitles by Rikke Nielsen